Belgians King Philippe visited the site
of the crash the entire nation is
mourning the tragic death of the 11
skydivers the plane nosedived into a
field near fennel mall southeast of
brussels just 20 minutes after taking
off eyewitnesses say part of a wing
broke off sending the plane spiraling to
the ground like you continue the wing
dropped like a jelly in the middle C
advocacy the plane continued for a bit
maybe 20 meters callate it's like so but
then it took a nosedive directly into
the ground if you get two more lonely
seconds later we heard a big explosion
if he used to Quantico knock on the
booboo adding to the tragedy the trip
was a birthday present a group of
experienced parachutists wanted to
welcome their friend to the world of
skydiving Prime Minister Elio Di Rupo
was visibly shaken also there are no
words to describe what happened and no
words for what the victims families are
going through right now we can only pray
that one day the vines he's authorities
have recovered three open parachutes
three of the passengers apparently tried
to escape by jumping out of the plane
but their attempt came too late